fight Samson his shot doesn't get through darene
trying to stick handle at the Blue Line and that
is stolen and here's a break back the other way
Tomer faced a number of those in the last game
that one from slapovi does not find the back of
the net and the Sabers survive that moment Sean
Mahan will play it down below the goal line and
the Canadians make a couple of changes that's
goes to the bench Monahan with Tanner Pearson and
Gallagher for the Canadians now here's Pearson his
shot stopped by com the rebound was there for
Gallagher but he was knocked to the ice comes
back to the line and not shot by zakai stop
but the rebound is fired in the back of the
net Justin Barrett has open the scoring here for
Montreal one nothing 1704 remaining in the first
anything pretty problem here is comry had to make
two big saves and when he made the saves put the
puck back out big big rebounds a long ways out and
not able to get back across takes a look at the
net shooting Lane's not there yet Canadians with
the one- nothing lead olison looking for the lane
Petco with a shot patch save and that's possession
in the eyes of the referee and we get the
call Montreal is the the most penalized team in
the NHL right now Dan averaging 23 8 py minutes
per game so he need to take advantage of it
and they do Jeff Skinner from the bottom of
the right Circle RS it home and the Sabers tie it
early on this power play Sabers win the face off
get it back to the point you get everybody spread
out here's the quick pass down to Skinner Allen's
got his shoulder on that post but it looks like it
goes Far Side when he takes this oh it goes short
side AC one bar across to the other and into the
net so I think Allen anticipating a pass to the
front not expecting a shot from Skinner being
that far down towards the goal line he sends
it across trying to find some room Victor ol of
good hard push on that far side and eventually
playing it below the goal line for K turns and
fires off the side of the net sski on top of
him now Thompson tried to fish it free Canadians
looking to skate out Dylan cousins stopped the
initial rush but it's a two-on one anyway back
the other way SL kowsky with a shot stopped by
cry motor homes they have to work out of trailers
yeah but it's amazing when they're doing their
job they have to give them a Pat the back yeah
and when it comes to odd man rushes Marty Puck
goes down to the far corner and Thompson will feed
it ahead up to Center Ice Greenway with Thompson
trailing he'll find the P cousins one timer oh
what a s by Allen let's watch this play coming
down he's going to want to feed it right here
cage Thompson comes in look at the shot he's got
himself ready he's got his body turned already he
knows this pass is going to come and if it is he's
going to be 100% ready it hits his stick and bang
it's off and that was the first point by Montreal
defenseman here so far this year here's Coffield
intercept sends it to the front of the net good
patch save by Comer as Coffield sets up Harvey
penard Comer had the answer and now back the
other way zus Genson he plls his way down the left
board so much so that he loses the Bonet he's got
to go to the bench Kyle poso Ian Jo now Clifton
takes the shot and the rebound in front just now
covered up Skinner along the goal line didn't mind
that angle in the first period here's dolene Far
Side Skinner cousins as they work it nice rebound
tuck Skinner back for tuck in front find the back
of the net here's darene slides this one across
little give and go and that's cousins with the
first shot tuck not able to follow it up and tuck
it in and they try to find T Thompson but it's
intercepting the Canadians with a potential two
onone to the net comery with the save short-handed
opportunity here for the Montreal Canadians
there's the quick shot Thompson on the far
boards 30 seconds to go on the p power play great
pass in front bumps again and Allen with the save
and it comes back to the line darene Thompson
he'll turn it back to the point saard force wide
down to the goal line he plays it in behind the
neck he try to return it in front and that can't
get it the length of the ice Sabers will be good
to push this quickly back into the Montreal Zone
and they do nice presence there to keep the heat
on Skinner tried to bang it in at the far post
stilling cousins behind the net Canadians
keeping everything to the outside in this
specific possession so far Sabers try to work it
in Greenway to Thompson and that one was blocked
inetta plays it around and that's
intercepted now Greenway at Center
will reach for it here's Greenway across
the line with a shot and it go save by
Allen here's the end of this one where
Greenway goes down and gets the shot on
if you've noticed a couple times tonight because
he talks so much he if you had him in myy in the
same spot at the same time oh my goodness Casey
midd plays it back in behind the net but now
room to bring it back for Tanner Pearson he'll
get it up Center Ice take the return pass left
side Pearson in the safe result sweep Salin
in front and C got the P down but it squeaks
in and Gallagher that's where Gallagher makes
his money right front of the net and he pokes
it home in Montreal with 1629 remaining in
the third period of taking a two to1 lead in
the front of the net not a big guy but he pays a
price and he gets there look at this first whack
second whack finally Finds Its way through com's
patch there's the first save and you see Gallagher
just bury his head give a little push there and
it goes through the five hole goes off the left
pad right pad on the save the left pad after he
pushes it through is there any chance they're
going to look no and four already to enter the
zone as power carries it in Coffield gets back
defensively Puck goes behind the net Thompson
to the side of the net with that puck rolling
right in front and Diving out to cover that
one up heck of a shift Skinner back to Tage
Thompson here Savers you're thinking now is
a time you got to isolate him yeah here's a
shot by Thompson The Rebound in front SAR can't
get there Thompson keeps it in Skinner one timer
glove save by Allen in front of the puck here's
power fan on the shot Tanner Pearson feeding it
ahead to Suzuki back to Pearson at Center
Canadian short-handed and Cy with a gain
saving stop right there with power play time
remaining here for buffalo power will just
dump it to the far Corner as Suzuki might have
got a piece of that one now the puck comes in
front and a save by comre there on Michael petta
as he got to it penalty penalty coming up here
as it's up by Krebs looking to get it to the
front of the net Monahan is there Anderson in
the high bumper slot there's a shot off the
post Savers get a break there and then it's
tipped just wide try to work it into the bumper
comes back off top to jacan 13 seconds to go on
the man Advantage zovsky coming off the boards
Far Side plays it across to new hook to the goal
line bumped in front and a one timer by Pearson
gives Montreal the twogo goal lead with 307 to
go that's going to be Tanner Pearson's third
goal of the Year here gives him a two goal
cushion now Montreal just moving this around the
perimeter and the Quick Pass from Gallagher right
back out to Pearson Pearson gets himself in a
good sweet spot right there No Sa within about
six or seven feet from him and he's able
to get that shot off clean and beat comry
and that will do it Montreal Gallagher at
Center fighting for the puck in the empty net
just wide the horn sou to and game number one
of this season series and it goes to Montreal